ich will ihnen noch ein mann vorstellen
der ferdinand pfahl ist er ist bestatter
in bonn und schönen guten abend herr
pfeil wir sehen sie hier bei ihrer
sowieso traurigen arbeit in diesen tagen
aber bei einer arbeit die wohl auch sie
fassungslos macht den guten abend pfahl
mittlerweile haben sie wie viele
flutopfer wie viele leichen bei sich in
der leichenhalle die sie bestatten
müssen 26 haben wir zu zeigen die sind
immer alle bei uns die sind teilweise
mit gerichtsmedizinischen gebracht
wurden
also sowas habe ich meinem leben noch
nie gesehen
was sind das für menschen die bei ihnen
nun verstorben in der leichenhalle
liegen in den vergangenen tagen als
flutopfer zu ihm gekommen sind sind dass
ältere menschen sind junge menschen
durch schmeckt alles also klein
angefangen von einer mitarbeiterin wurde
morgens um 6 uhr geweckt dass ihr mann
ein feuerwehrmann tödlich verunglückt
imker leitungen ist jetzt die letzte
wahl liegt 23 jährige die noch gesucht
worden ist das sind alles möglich am
menschen erhalten junge große klein weil
das ist einfach nur schrecklich ist
unheimlich viele probleme gehabt die
abzuholen durchs wasser steine geröll
mussten wir abholen das war ja wie in
dem krieg wo stehe ich und krieg wann
war bei ihnen der zeitpunkt dass sie
gespürt haben dass es eine ganz
besondere katastrophe ganz unglaublichen
ausmaßes ja mittwoch
wir fahren normalerweise alles im kreis
euskirchen für der polizei
da kamen sind polizeiauto abhol und weil
man keine verbindung mehr hatten
wir haben uns gebeten möglichst viele
teams zusammenzustellen mit den hinter
blauen schwer zu fahren weil die straßen
teilweise gesperrt waren also mittwoch
waren wir ungefähr klar dass eine riesen
katastrophe ist aber dass sie so groß
wurde
damit habe ich überhaupt nicht gerechnet
ist irgendwo auch man kann jetzt sagen
wir verliert die lust aber es muss immer
irgendwo weiter gehen wir danken ihnen
für ihre so schwierige arbeit auch in
diesen tagen tatsächlich erschreckende
bilder bei ihnen aus ihren leichenhallen
von immer mehr sagen infolge dieser
flugkatastrophe danke für das gespräch
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren